you're mentioning like crack starting to
appear
um and I know you wrote a piece about
Silicon Valley Banks downfall being the
canary and the coal mine can we just
explore that a bit further
um so the canary in the coal mine is
meant to reflect two things uh first
that the
um it's not
just the Silicon Valley Bank it is a
pervasive
thing about holding a lot of debt that
has gone down in value
um and being leveraged long so it's a
pervasive thing and also meant to convey
that there's a sequence of events that
are like dominoes falling so for example
those who are hurt
financially and have a lot of that
debt don't want to buy more of that debt
yet the government is going to have to
sell the debt in other words when they
run run a deficit that means they have
to sell bonds and they're
um and all of those who have bought
bonds including foreigners
um who are increasingly worried about
um even uh the value of the debt
um but also uh sanctions sanctions means
that you know you freeze the debt um so
certain holders of the debt say I've got
a lot of US dollar denominated debt and
I already have maybe too much and then
do I want to buy more and so you have
um an imbalance there in terms of
selling and buying which is a risky
situation in addition there's this
sequence of events that takes place such
as
um those who were making loans
uh Banks who now are suffering from this
condition don't want to make as much
loans and so if you look at let's say
like Regional Banks those Regional Banks
make a lot of loans to for uh
residential real estate excuse me
commercial real estate although so
there's a problem with residential too
but so if you look at
um real estate commercial real estate
um there's
um it it's vulnerable and they but they
haven't
gotten the consequences that are yet to
come in the form of running out of
adequate cash flow and not having the
money and then having to sell assets and
so on